Now we're ready to start creating canvas tiles to cache some of our draw calls.
We'll put this functionality in our preDrawCache function. We need to walk
through our map tiles and for each tile create a new canvas tile container of
the correct width Height and x, y position in the world. After this we need to
push each canvas style into a new array that we've made to keep track of them
inside our TILEDmap class. So finally we don't want to set the fully loaded flag
until true until after canvas styles have been created and filled in. So we've
modified our image loading code. Call back. To rather than actually setting the
flag, it calls preDrawCache and said. Once all of our canvasses have been filled
in, we can then safely set fullyloaded equal to true, so that rendering can
continue in the future.